llena los espacios para completar la
ecuación y tenemos 5 mil 267 punto 3 es
igual a cinco millares más dos centenas
más cinco decenas más algo en unidades
más tres décimas como vamos a sacar este
número vamos a reagrupar cada cada valor
posicional y lo vamos a reescribir para
tener la igualdad tenemos cinco mil 267
puntos tres este cinco este cinco se
encuentra en las unidades de millar
vamos a colocarlo aquí como
más este 2 se encuentra en la posición
de las centenas dos centenas doscientos
este 6 se encuentra en la posición de
las decenas seis decenas o sesenta más
el siete que se encuentra en las
unidades siete unidades y si sumamos la
parte de las decimales tendremos que
este tres está en el valor posicional de
tres décimos
de esta manera hemos reagrupado cada
número cada valor posicional y podemos
entonces hacer la ecuación
hagamos un poco más de espacio porque
esto está muy apretado
ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo con el lado
derecho tenemos cinco millares vamos a
colocar los millares exactamente en el
mismo color que hemos usado cinco
millares cinco unidades de millar son
cinco mil más dos centenas las centenas
están en color verde más dos centenas
doscientos más cinco decenas aquí
tenemos seis decenas aquí hay una
diferencia cinco decenas
[Música]
algo en unidades
y finalmente sumaremos tres décimas
vamos a hacer una comparativa tres
décimas tenemos en ambos lados tenemos
cinco unidades de millar en ambos lados
dos centenas en ambos lados realmente la
diferencia se encuentra entre las
decenas y las unidades
y aquí tenemos 67 son 67 y en este lado
solo tenemos 50 cuál es la diferencia
que tenemos para que este 50 se vuelva
67 17 vamos a ponerlo con anaranjado
y de esta manera tenemos la igualdad en
la ecuación pudiéramos llegar aquí
diciendo que tenemos 17 unidades pero
esto significa 17 unidades si esto
significa 17 por 1
así es que podemos llenar ahora sí aquí
nuestro cuadro donde podemos establecer
la igualdad de 5.267 punto 3 y si
ustedes suman 5.250 más 17 más 3 decimos
nos da exactamente el mismo número a que
lo que realmente hicimos aquí lo que
quisimos fue reagrupar de las decenas
tomamos toda una decena
y la reagrupamos hacia las unidades se
dan cuenta de 60 convertimos 50 + 10 y
estos 7 se convirtieron en 17 lo único
que hicimos fue reagrupar esta escena
hacia las unidades y con eso tenemos
nuestra equivalencia sin problemas
espero haber sido clara nos vemos en
otro vídeo